at CES 2014 PC manufacturers big and
small are racing to unveil their take on
Valve's steam machine but a lien layer
is already wetting the appetites of
early adopters with their announcement
of its own steam machine its yet
nameless little black box roughly eight
inches by 8 inches in size smaller than
it's already tiny x51 Mini Tower is
relatively small in the gaming PC market
it's likely that alien wear is going to
offer a few different variants of their
machine the different specs and price
tags match of course with consoles and
other steam machines as direct
competitors it's fair to expect that
Illinois is offering will be comparable
in price and performance to either the
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 while we
don't have exact specifications just yet
what we can say is that it will be
running on an Intel CPU and an NVIDIA
GPU with it they're shipping valves
steam OS control but this is the result
of a partnership rather than an
exclusive agreement with valve that said
Alienware steam machine can only be
purchased with steam OS pre-installed
although users will be able to shift to
the Windows operating system if they
choose expect more details on Alienware
steam machine around the time of PAX
East later this spring until then stay
tuned a game spot for more coverage of
Alienware smallest gaming PC and other
steam machines from the show floor at
CES 2014